if
[Music]
chief
not even one spicy
so
so
you've got a taste for adventure too huh
i must say the patrons have been in a
bit of a buzz lately
though the topic on everyone's lips is
more of an urban legend than actual news
even minding my own business i still end
up hearing all about it
uh-oh
it's not one of those scary urban
legends is it
if so pima needs to take a deep breath
first
[Laughter]
it's not a particularly scary story no
at least
not for most people it's the tale of
the dark knight hero
huh did the bartender just say something
you weren't even listening
anyway
the dark knight hero
it is said that he appears in the middle
of the night to fight evil and uphold
justice
but to be honest i don't have much
interest in such rumors
unless of course he can help take care
of the more belligerent patrons after
they've had a few too many
i would happily take that as proof of
his existence
i'm told that there have been a handful
of sightings
but in the depths of night no one can
get a good look at him
perhaps that's why he only appears at
night
nevertheless the sightings confirm that
the dark knight hero is more than just a
groundless rumor
[Laughter]
anyway
that's more or less everything i know
if you want to know more ask around in
the plaza
ah
i need to serve some customers
dark knight hero
seems like your standard cookie cutter
urban legend
but just a little darker
i wonder who it could be once you're
ready let's head out to the plaza and
ask
would you around
look no further
it's me
you're right
jokes aside i do think that the dark
what's that
it's
the way he sticks to his principles
coming out here night after night
fighting for justice keeping monstat
safe
wow so you're a nocturnal vigilante too
no i just mean he must be seriously rich
why is that
people only start worrying about
spiritual fulfillment once they have
enough material wealth
it's the same in every hero story isn't
it
no it's nothing like that i just have
too much time on my hands these days
same difference you are the boss the
cats tale after all why don't you ask
the guards at the city gate
they do night shifts all the time they
must know something
it's
you want to know about him
in fact i'm one of the few who has seen
him with my own two eyes
great this is the guy we need to talk to
so
just who is the dark knight hero
whoa slow slow down
let me start from the beginning
well
i was patrolling one night when suddenly
i heard something
i rushed over to check it out
i saw a gang of suspicious looking
fellows who looked like they were up to
no good
so i quickly hid
head
you're supposed to be a guard
that was when he appeared
he was dressed in black from head to toe
perfectly hidden in the night
the way he crept up on those bad guys
must have felt like a living nightmare
wow
guess what i did next
i would probably have just gotten in the
way as far as the dark knight hero is
concerned
so instead
i headed to the knights of fivonius's
residence
correct
i thought surely someone with such a
strong sense of justice and who
voluntarily protects monstat is exactly
the kind of person you'd find in the
nights of fivonius
but it seems i was wrong
i checked everywhere and there were no
signs of anyone having left the building
so you're saying whoever it is can't be
from the knights of evonius after all
yes
but i just can't understand
why would someone like that
not want to join the knights i'm sure
they would warmly welcome someone of his
abilities
so
the point you're trying to make is
you don't know who the dark knight hero
is either
hey don't be like that
at least by talking to me you've ruled
out a few more people
anyway try asking at the flower shop
i heard a girl there's been talking
about the time you rescued
her welcome to monstat
what's that
can't you give me a better price
better see barbara at the cathedral if
you're injured
what's wrong with why can't i get him
out of uh help my hero
oh is it that obvious oh no
what am i going to do
if master d luke ever finds out
huh
let's do
well
i used to think d luke was the one for
me but ever since the time i was rescued
by the darkness wow
you it all happens all i remember is
seeing a flash of fire
but i felt safe
hmm
perhaps it you know
okay then so base all we need to do is
find a wealthy vision-wielding vid hmm
but we already asked so many let's take
a look around the city at night of
course they're flowers it's getting dark
let's stick around monster maybe if
we're lucky we'll meet the dark knight
hero
you've got to try don winery
uh
after managing to steer clear of the
guard's patrol route i never anticipated
i'd run into you dark knight hero
how is this the first you've heard of
the name every man in his dog in monstat
is yapping about the dark knight hero
i do not concern myself with idol
chatter
though i suppose i may take the idleness
of others as a sign that peace prevails
huzzah the great mystery of the dark
knight hero of monster we solved it
now then mr dark knight hero please stop
calling me that
seriously it makes me uncomfortable
not surprised it's the stupidest
superhero name pymon's ever heard you
should come up with something more
original
like
um captain
pine
pie
captain tell us captain pirate
it was the abyss order then again i
don't know what the devil they're
plotting this time
it seems they're performing some initial
reconnaissance
considering that i've proven myself to
be one step ahead of them on countless
occasions
their persistence is
unusual
who would be helping whom is debatable
the knights are for the most part an
utterly incompetent bunch
i cannot trust them to take this matter
over
that's not my point
i'm not doing this to impress anyone
well
i hope this conversation has been of
service to you
because i would like to ask for a favor
in return
oh what is it master d luke your wish is
our command
you must keep my identity a secret
above all it is crucial that you do not
let the knights of favonius know i am
connected to any of this
what's that sound they appear to just be
small timer i cannot afford delays on
account of a few remember don't tell a
soul
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings
did you see anything out nope
unless you're looking for the dark
knight hero in which case
the dark knight hero oh
uh the dark knight hero you
the hero who safeguards monsted from the
shadow
wait a second aren't you the rumors were
circulating about the dark oh
why would you lie to me about
but i do hope you will visit the nights
some things are but
duty calls